Ant-Man And The Wasp's post-credit scenes
finally answer the question: where was Ant-Man
in Avengers: Infinity War?
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the two post-credits
scenes in Ant-Man And The Wasp, explaining
their connection to Infinity War and how they
set us up for Avengers 4.
If you're new here, I do regular superhero
videos plus I'm kicking off a new Marvel giveaway.
Make sure you're subscribed and leave a comment
about the movie to enter.
Spoilers ahead for Ant-Man And The Wasp and
Infinity War.
The mid-credits scene opens with Scott Lang
preparing to head back into the Quantum Realm
on a mission to collect quantum healing particles.
Janet van Dyne warns Scott to stay away from
Tardigrades and not to get sucked into a time
vortex.
Once inside the Quantum Realm, Scott collects
some healing particles, then reports he's
ready to come back.
Hope counts down his return over the mic 5...
4... 3... but then the line goes dead.
As the camera cuts back to where Hope, Janet
and Hank were operating the Quantum tunnel,
we see the remains of 3 clouds of ash falling
to little piles on the floor.
Basically, the Pym family has been dusted
by Thanos's snap at the end of Avengers: Infinity
War.
It's a really ominous moment when you hear
Scott's panicked voice over the mic as the
camera pans through little clouds of ash.
He realises something's wrong but has no idea
what.
The scene is also a chilling reminder of the
Infinity War post-credits scene where Nick
Fury and Maria Hill evaporated into ash in
New York.
It's especially tough to watch as Hope only
suited up as the Wasp in this movie.
And Janet van Dyne was only just rescued from
the Quantum Realm, and now we have to see
them dusted.
Wasp will be in Avengers 4, however, Evangeline
Lilly has said she's only going to be in it
a little which is disappointing as it seems
she'll probably be limited to just scenes
where she returns with the other dusted heroes.
Now, there is a glimmer of hope no pun intended
in Janet's last words to Scott about time
vortices in the Quantum Realm.
Avengers 4 is very likely to be set several
years after the snap in a film that I expect
will show the surviving Avengers adjusting
to a decimated world and figuring out what
they can do about it.
Marvel has cast a currently 16-year old Emma
Fuhrmann to play an older version of Scott's
daughter Cassie in Avengers 4, which means,
I expect, that once Scott realises that there's
no one at the other end in the real world
to bring him back, he may try travelling through
a time vortex.
This could take him into the future where
he meets an older Cassie and then together
they visit Tony Stark to tell him about the
Quantum Realm, and the Avengers then try to
figure out how they can use time travel to
fix what Thanos did.
This would tie in with the Avengers 4 set
photos of Ant-Man in New York with Iron Man
and Captain America with each of them wearing
a similar looking device around their wrist.
Another possibility for how Scott escapes
from the Quantum Realm could tie in with Captain
Marvel.
I expect a reason will be revealed in her
film as to why Carol Danvers hasn't been around
or available during the various crises we've
seen on Earth, such as the Battle of New York,
Sokovia, or Infinity War itself.
It could be that she's in the Quantum Realm
herself.
And the beeper that Nick Fury set off to contact
her in the Infinity War post-credits scene
may be able to communicate with Carol there.
Ant-Man might hear the beeper while he's stuck
there too.
And he and Carol might both even meet up in
a Captain Marvel post-credits scene that sets
them up to meet the Avengers in Avengers 4.
Another possibility is that Scott simply gets
stuck in the Quantum Realm for several years
and learns new secrets and survives there,
just like Janet did.
His daughter Cassie could eventually find
out where the mobile Quantum tunnel was located
and so she turns it on again to bring him
back out.
What's also interesting in this credits scene
is that Scott was collecting Quantum healing
particles.
These were being gathered to help Ghost, however,
there's a chance they could also play a role
in restoring the heroes who were dusted in
the Thanos snap.
There is a second post-credits scene which,
while short, does provide a little more backdrop
for Avengers 4.
After all the credits have rolled, we snap
back to Scott's house which seems to be deserted.
Everything is quiet except for the dissonant
tone of an emergency broadcast playing on
a TV screen, indicating the Thanos snap has
truly kicked off a crisis.
This sense of unease is followed with a shot
of the ant who filled in for Scott during
his house arrest playing the drums.
It's an uncomfortable moment watching the
ant drumming away as he seems oblivious to
the catastrophe around him.
And just to unsettle us even further, as the
screen fades to black, a title card pops up
with the words "Ant-Man and the Wasp will
return", but a little question mark is added
after a second or two.
We can't take this last bit too seriously
as I think Marvel is just gently trolling
us because as I said earlier, it's already
been confirmed that Evangeline Lilly does
return in Avengers 4.
Now, I'd love to hear your theories on Avengers
4.
And if you've seen Ant-Man And The Wasp, what
did you think of the movie?
Let me know in the comments and make sure
you're subscribed to enter my Marvel giveaway.
I'm working on new Marvel videos so until
then tap left to check out one of my videos
YouTube thinks you'll like or tap right for
my full Marvel playlist including Infinity
War.
If you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and your
support is really appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!